does glenn close regret doing the butt
at the oscars
not one bit glenn you know you won the
oscars and everybody is talking about it
that's da but let me see it
[Music]
what have you heard from people since
that moment
well i was so touched by a lot of the
press that came out
i mean to me that was a great revelation
spike lee
and his family called me and you know
it's just it just opened up
i think something that people were
really joyous about remembering
and and revisiting and i hope they have
a comeback
now glenn is getting back to what has
made her an eight-time oscar-nominated
powerhouse
it just goes on and on i'm so sorry
that my drug addiction is so incredibly
difficult on you she co-stars in the
emotionally charged drama four good days
out today
glenn plays the desperate mother of a
heroin addict portrayed by a
barely recognizable mila kunis last time
we used
yesterday morning so i'm hurting
what was it like making that
transformation and how did you shed it
to go home every night
it didn't um i mean i looked what i
looked like
um how is it making the transformation
very freeing also i
look like that at drop off at school and
i look like that i pick up and i look at
that when i take my
use and how you lost weight for that and
you're so tiny to begin with
mila revealed she dropped down to the
same weight as her character in black
swan
which was reportedly around 95 pounds
yeah that's temporary like i don't
recommend doing that
much harder to lose weight gaining
weight back was real easy guys that one
took me no time
please i can't do that yes you can glenn
the way you
encapsulize the angst of a parent not
wanting to give up on their child
what was that like internalizing that
it's just heartbreaking
and knowing that this was a true story
i was very inspired by that only e.t sat
down with the real-life mother-daughter
duo
libby alexander and amanda wendler there
are some times where mila looks
really rough in this what was that like
for you that was the hardest part for me
is being seeing that and you know it's
you know it's based on my life and
i did go through a period where i didn't
look so good
you know so that was really hard seeing
that you think it's my fault
that you're an addict this story is also
what we do want for trade because
recovery
um it happens and it was exciting to see
glenn close playing me i never thought
that would happen in my whole entire
life
you